[Música]
segundo y último bloque económico del
día y también de la semana con luís
méndez luis bienvenida nuevamente feliz
viernes otra vez vamos a iniciar con la
preocupación que existe en reino unido
por el impacto que podría tener el
sector turístico con el incremento de
los casos de kobe 19 asociados con esta
nueva variante lado micro
personas viajen y hagan turista en
diversas partes del mundo pero de
acuerdo con el medio británico que
coordina las cancelaciones en las
reservas de hoteles se están
incrementando en los últimos días debido
al temor de esta nueva variante louis
que para interrumpirlo es que tenemos un
problema con el micrófono ya sólo vamos
a encender para que puedan escuchar los
televidentes lo que está hablando porque
el único que estaba prestando la
atención ahora estoy yo porque no lo
estaba escuchando nadie jajaja si
adelante vamos a hablar entonces
retomamos lo que estábamos diciendo
sobre esta variante omicron en reino
unido- y el impacto que puede tener el
sector turístico y específicamente en el
sector hotelero porque de acuerdo con el
medio británico 'the guardian' las
cancelaciones en las reservas se han
incrementado durante los últimos días
debido al temor de esta nueva variante
la publicación que cita a la franquicia
best western hotel group señala que el
sector responsabiliza de las
cancelaciones a los mensajes
contradictorios que han emitido los
ministros durante los últimos días pero
en abril de 2021 previo a la llegada del
verano y el levantamiento de
restricciones en la nación que
beneficiaron completamente turismo okay
hospitality señala que en este sector se
perdieron alrededor de 80 mil millones
de libras esto es más de 107 mil
millones de dólares pero de acuerdo con
este mismo organismo para disminuir el
impacto económico de las cancelaciones
emitieron un comunicado en el que
retoman anuncios ctera o ms que indican
que los casos de esta variante parecen
ser leves esto podría presentarse como
un impulso a su juicio necesario para el
sector ahora así que todo el mundo lo
está escuchando hablemos de argentina
porque se cumplen 20 años de lo que fue
el corralito en el año 2001 louis así es
estamos hablando específicamente del
decreto
1578 de presidente fernando de la rúa y
que fue conocido como ya lo adelanta
como corralito lo que buscaba esta
medida era evitar la fuga masiva de
capitales al extranjero pero el gobierno
que a su vez en negociaba una
reestructuración de deuda con el fondo
monetario internacional
evitar que esto generará un impacto
político y social dentro de la
administración dos décadas han
transcurrido de aquellos sucesos que
provocaron un aumento de 12 puntos por
venzo porcentuales en la pobreza y ha
llevado a que argentina en la actualidad
presente una nueva crisis económica y
también esté negociando una
reestructuración de deuda con el fondo
monetario internacional sin embargo a
diferencia de lo ocurrido en el año 2001
los economistas en la nación han
manifestado que no hay posibilidad de
que se presente un nuevo corralito pero
a propósito del acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional el presidente
alberto fernández durante la noche de
ayer se pronunció al respecto volvió a
recurrir que va a pagar pero esta vez
sin que ello implique una medida un
impacto para la economía de la nación
escuchemos
afrontaremos las deudas que otros
generaron
pero ese acuerdo no será a costa del
desarrollo del país y en base a ningún
programa de ajuste todos ustedes saben
que el préstamo otorgado al argentino en
para que entiendan su magnitud es
equivalente a toda la ayuda que ese
organismo dio al mundo para sobrellevar
los daños causados por la pandemia por
eso le pedimos al fondo monetario
internacional que antes que cerremos un
nuevo acuerdo haga su evaluación de lo
que fue el fallido programa stand by por
qué por el que se desembolsaron 44 mil
millones de dólares que se mal
utilizaron en pagar deuda insostenible y
en financiar salida de capitales louis y
hablando del fondo monetario
internacional hay cambios dentro de esa
organización cuáles son así es raúl es
que a través de un comunicado el
organismo manifestó que el actual
economista jefe chiíta opina está
ocupará el segundo cargo en importancia
dentro de él mismo el fondo monetario
internacional anuncia que el primer
subdirector gerente geoffrey okamoto
dejará su cargo el próximo año y se
propone allí está capital para ocupar
este puesto el anuncio se produce meses
después de que copyright había anunciado
su salida del organismo multilateral
para regresar a la vida académica
combinada de 49 años seamos agradecida
por el llamado louis entonces gracias
por toda la información económica en
este último bloque económico de la
semana feliz fin de semana para ti a
menos de una vez a parís ahí está lista
erika olavarría